new state laws go into effect tomorrow
one of which focuses on gun safety eight
news now reporter Madison Kimbrough went
to a gun range to find out how this will
impact business
starting Saturday Senate Bill 294 will
go into effect requiring a licensed
dealer to provide a locking device
securing a firearm with each sail or
transfer having a firearm and being able
to protect yourself is one side of
safety but locking it up and making sure
it isn't used against you is the other
side of it Chris chansky general manager
of the range 702 says this new law
changes nothing at her gun range as
safety has always been their top
priority in properly locking up your
firearm is of the utmost importance for
years almost every single gun
manufacturer has been providing a lock
with every gun sale so it's something
that's kind of already standard within
the industry it's something that we
always talk about and provide to our
customers and as for how someone goes
about locking up their firearm so take a
look here's the law and as you're going
to see there's the cord it's going to go
through the gun up top you're going to
reach through and lock it in place
you're going to take this gun and as you
can see the magazine will not go through
along with this new law comes signs
telling the public about safe storage a
requirement for all licensed dealers to
have in their stores and although
chansky is pleased to see steps being
taken to prevent Reckless gun violence
she says she doesn't see it making much
of a difference so I think it's
important to have these conversations
obviously we can look at our country we
know there are problems I don't think a
sign is going to solve them